new CBA some months ago we're now
currently in that it looked like one of
the major thrusts of that of course was
to try to make it extremely difficult if
not impossible to create super teams uh
Phoenix is sort of doing it anyway I'm
curious how you feel about uh the way
the system is or is not working already
with respect to that and then uh
unrelated but I'm just gonna jam it in
there anyway
um James Harden Damian Lillard are have
both issued trade demands you guys have
had to act on some respect or another on
both those because of the way they
became public those things are still
kind of hanging out there with the
Camp's a few weeks away and we went
through this you've talked in the past
about trade demands and Forest trades
the whole Ben Simmons Saga so I know you
have some feelings of that as well so uh
curious about both of those yeah you
know Howard in in terms of trade demands
of course don't like them as a league
want players and teams to honor their
contracts and I'm watching both the
situation in Portland and Philadelphia
and hope hope they get worked out to the
satisfaction of everyone before the
season starts and I'm glad that things
seem to have settled down somewhat at
least in terms of public discourse on
super teams just to be clear
I think from a league standpoint we love
super teams as long as they're formed in
a way that seem competitively Fair
across the league
smart drafting you know smart trades Etc
as opposed to one team has the ability
to spend an enormous amount more than
another team does and I think the new
Provisions in this collective bargaining
agreement go a long way towards a
leavening impact
across the league in terms of what any
team is doing this season as you know
there's a transition in terms of the new
rules so you asked specifically about
Phoenix
um
all in on anything that's appropriate
under the current rules and that
certainly is so to the extent that a
team sees an opportunity before the full
transition into the so-called second
apron and they see opportunity to do
things and are willing to pay the
appropriate tax that's perfectly
appropriate having said that you know
like all the things we do in the league
office we continue to learn and work
with our players and create better
systems so
I've seen now many versions of new
provisions and collective bargaining and
they almost never work
precisely the way they were designed and
our teams are super sophisticated and
it's their job to work the system and
figure out how to win so I'm sure we'll
see with these new Provisions once they
fully kick in we'll have a better sense
of how effective they are and maybe have
to go you know back to the table to see
if we can do a better job but lastly
just say I mean I think you know Joe
Dumar said this earlier today at our
meeting you know at least sort of in
modern NBA history I don't remember a
time when the league was so competitive
and one indication being we've had five
different teams win championships over
the last five years and going into this
season I think you could feel it in the
room with the team Governors a real
sense of excitement around this new
season so
um
you know I'm I'm pleased that at the
state of competition but again new CBA
let's see how these Provisions work
great